but we begin tonight with the democrats
their far
left socialist radical agenda it's
failing
in pretty much everywhere it's tried it
is
all self-destructive democrats now in
complete damage control they're trying
to rewrite history
trying to pretend as if they never held
these radical positions they have been
pushing
but people aren't buying they're running
away from their own radical stance
and the democratic party is fracturing
right before your eyes
now just look at the issue of voter id
where we're now seeing the most
shameless
the most bizarre the most brazen
flipping and flopping and turning around
with the likes of stacey abrams joe
biden raphael warnock and others
they're actually now trying to claim
they were never against voter id
never once and they're even claiming
they never made baseless claims about
voter id being part of quote
jim crow 2.0 voting reform laws in the
case of
abrams she clearly has a pretty short
memory
or more likely she's just straight up
lying joe biden stacey abrams warnock
they have cost georgia and georgia
businesses
an estimated hundred million dollars
just by losing the all-star game
alone luckily for joe stacy raphael we
actually have
tape of them and by the way we're happy
to refresh their memories take a look
redux of a failed system that is
designed to both
scare people out of voting and make it
harder for those who are willing to push
through
make it harder for them to vote just
give me a list
of the provisions that you objected
it shortens the federal runoff period
from nine weeks to four weeks
okay it restricts the time a voter can
request and return an absentee ballot
application
right it requires that a voter have a
photo identification
or some other form of identification
that they're willing to surrender
in order to participate in absentee
ballot
process that's one of the fallacies of
republican talking points have been
deeply disturbing
no one has ever objected to having to
prove who you are
to vote it's been part of our nation's
history since the inception of voting
abram is now saying she's even backing
democrat senator joe manchin and his
voting compromise
that it actually reportedly will be
similar to
georgia's voting law reform that abrams
and sippy cup joe biden were referring
to as jim crow 2.0 and woe corporations
like mlb cave to
cost the state of georgia hundreds of
millions of dollars and a lot of lies
told about the state
so could it be democrats they're
starting to see the writing is on the
wall
realize their positions on voter id so
many other issues
are as unpopular as ever look at this
monmouth university poll
it shows overwhelmingly the american
people support
voter picture id 91 percent of
republicans
87 percent of independents 62 percent of
democrats
and 84 percent of non-white americans
they support integrity and confidence in
elections and that means
photo voter id now what democrats call
jim crow 2.0
just a few short weeks ago is actually
popular with
americans all across the country it's
the first of this thing from voter
suppression
it's one of the few issues americans are
actually united on
but of course democrats they just keep
doubling down on lie after lie after
lie when you know joe and stacy and
rafael
there's they're spewing these lies when
do they apologize
for dividing this country and creating
racial division
like far left extremist georgia senator
rafael warnock he's flat out lying
trying to claim that he never opposed
voter id
despite numerous examples uncovered by
foxnews.com
going back years and what about
president sippy cup
why didn't he ever lift a finger he's
represented the state of delaware i
think about 5 000 years
and guess what he never lifted a finger
to create more accessibility
for voters in his state they don't have
any early voting like the state of
georgia does 17 days in person early
voting
they have no drop boxes in delaware uh
they don't have no excuse excuse
absentee ballots like they do in georgia
no he never lifted a fingered and by the
way when are they also
one of the mob in the media asked joe
any of the tough questions
about why he didn't lift a finger to
make voting
less restrictive in his home state or as
he calls it
i'm from a slave state the media they've
had meltdown after meltdown
when donald trump called them out for
their fake news
now just watch biden's behavior and you
ask yourself
what would the mob's reaction be if this
was donald trump let's take a look
how was your role as vice president in
in charge of policy in ukraine
in your son's job in ukraine how is that
not a conflict of interest
it's not a conflict of interest there's
been no indication of any conflict of
interest
from ukraine or anywhere else period i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna respond to that
let's focus on the problem focus on this
man
what he's doing that no president has
ever done
no president it's a long way until
november we got more questions
you got more questions but i tell it if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break man
good start thank you
you are subject to some degree of
cognitive
decline and he also partnered with a
klansman to stop integration of schools
didn't want schools becoming racial
junger
jungles his words now rather than
seriously cover sippy cup and his
failing agenda
his weakness abroad want to be
journalists well let's look at the new
york times
and their full-time donald trump stalker
maggie haberman
even as she is now supposed to be
covering biden well stalker maggie
appears to be obsessed still
with all things donald trump and mostly
ignoring the ever forgetful joe
because get this a review foxnews.com
it found that the new york times
published more than 40 stories
featuring maggie haberman in some
capacity
since the paper claims she would be
covering the biden administration
only five have been about biden with the
majority focused on donald trump
and remember it was stalker maggie
haberman and the new york times and
those partisan
socialist attacks remember they won the
once prestigious pulitzer prize in 2018
for their russia collusion coverage
which of course turned out to be
completely and
totally false totally based on bad
sources
bad information bad journalism bad
writing
and total fake news left wing
partisan radical agenda maggie i'll ask
again
when are you going to admit your
mistakes correct the record
return your fake pulitzer and admit who
you are
you've now become a full-time donald
trump stalker you're not covering
joe biden the way you cover donald trump
you're not capable of it
she stalks trump and gives biden the
pass just like her new york times
colleagues they just
all can't seem to quit donald trump the
mob the media
they miss trump more than anyone else in
the country
maybe maggie and other stalkers at the
new york times our colleagues
maybe they want us to get trump bobble
heads for them
so they can put pins in it at night
here's a headline
you know let's see trump stalkers at the
new york times need to return their fake
pulitzer
the new york times completely botched
their russian coverage
they were wrong again and again and
again they spread lie after
lie conspiracy theory after conspiracy
theory
to you the american people and it went
on for three long years
for example remember you know maggie
hagerman
stalking trump oh trump jr was told in
an email of russian effort to aid
campaign
that never ended up being that ended up
being a totally misleading story
it failed to explain that the lawyer in
the infamous trump tower meeting
was tied to fusion gps you know glenn
simpson
the guy that hired christopher steele to
put together
the fake hillary clinton bought and paid
for dirty russian disinformation dossier
and by the way later was used
uncorroborated
in fisa applications to spy on candidate
trump and later president trump
uh maggie and your fellow new york times
uh trump stalkers you blew the biggest
story in your career
you never told your readers the truth
you never told them that dossier was
garbage
full of lies propaganda russian
misinformation
you never told them that comey and the
fbi were warned repeatedly
about issues about christopher steele
this is not
journalism you know you have now become
basically the press office
for all things new green deal socialism
and if the pulitzer committee had any
integrity if you had any integrity if
the new york times had any integrity
you would return that bony pulitzer or
at least they'd take it back
maggie and her leftist hat colleagues at
the new york times they lied
they got a phony reward for it and the
paper tonight is already doing damage
control tweeting out
maggie haberman is one of the finest
journalists of her generation
uh no she's not and let me just say that
tweet will not
age well and speaking of sources well
what's the new york times telling their
readers about
joe biden the weak frail cognitive
mess that is joe biden uh have they
really done a deep dive into joe's
schedule less than what one one item a
day
what his staff is really you know
thinking about him
why aren't they investigating those
important stories because we know
so-called reporters at the new york
times and elsewhere
they're nothing but an extension of the
democratic new green deal socialist
party
they amplify the same lies the same
agenda
they smear republicans they obsess over
trump
they hide truth they protect democrats
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else